welcome back to CBS Saturday morning
with Thanksgiving less than a week away
a focus this morning on those who raise
the birds on our table there are more
than 2500 turkey farms across the
country many Raising small flocks in a
year where everything is more expensive
those costs have hit Family Farms
especially hard as Janet shamlian found
in rural Indiana
Kyle Becker is like many of our nation's
small farmers
98 acres in Moorland Indiana on which he
raises turkeys cattle chicken and pigs
his second job as a veterinarian is
essential farming alone doesn't cut it
for your family no ma'am does it come
close no ma'am as far as paying weekly
monthly bills for our family
it is it is not a business that you can
rely on year in and year out to be
productive Becker Farms is a family
operation his wife Emily keeps the books
the couple's five young children helped
too how much does she weigh 25 pounds
turkeys are the focus this time of year
these are the last of 6200 he produced
for Thanksgiving a season where he
raised prices 60 cents a pound but will
earn far less than in years past
you're charging more for turkeys this
year yes we're up about nine eight nine
percent but your profits are down yeah
we cut our profit margin in half why
because otherwise I won't be able to
sell them
Becker says he's paying more for diesel
fuel labor even packaging but his
biggest expense is feed up 40 percent in
a year turkey prices this year compared
to last year are prices are higher we're
up about 25 to 35 percent across the
different sizes and toms versus hens
David Anderson is an agricultural
Economist at Texas A M University who
says there will be plenty of turkeys
available despite bird flu wiping out
more than 7 million Nationwide the
turkeys will be there but you know they
may cost a little more than they than
last year the average price of a whole
frozen bird is 2.45 cents a pound up 70
cents per pound though plenty of stores
offer bargain Birds to get you in the
door back on Becker Farms it's been a
tough year but Kyle says they're in it
for the long haul the reason that we can
continue to do business is last year we
made really good money and so this year
we'll make quite a bit less and then at
you know after Thanksgiving turkey
season we'll reevaluate not all the news
is false as these birds were headed out
for processing a last minute reprie um
now this one won't go for Thanksgiving
okay this is our pardon term this is a
pardon train for CBS Saturday morning
Janet shamlia Moreland Indiana
so glad one one
lucky pardoned you wanna do your gobble
[Music]
wow yeah I'm gonna pass all right